now the good news
it may take me somebody else a year to
get somebody's leaky gut seal i was
naive when i started this i said a
couple weeks you'll be fine
no
but the good news is once you seal leaky
gut
we find that you become
desensitized against most of these foods
in fact
i gave a paper the american heart
association and lifestyle and
epidemiology meeting two years ago
showing that 94
of people
who had celiac disease and profound
gluten intolerance
in a year 94 of them no longer had any
antibodies to gluten their immune system
literally was retrained that gluten was
not an issue for them anymore
so
i mean
we find that once you seal the gut by
removing these things and once you you
literally can retrain the immune system
not to react to these substances and
that's why
so many of my patients if i can convince
them
that yeah i'm going to make you
miserable in the foods i'm going to take
away from you but if we seal your gut
and most the time we can
we'll get these things back into your
diet and and it'll be worth it long term
wow so essentially
the
like testing for food sensitivities
given the fact that yes the things that
you eat show up in your diet because of
course like you said it passes through
particles that are way too big your body
doesn't understand it it hasn't been
broken down
so it's really just an indication of in
your
experience that lectins being probably
the number one thing to eliminate maybe
it needs to be a little more specific as
it goes but that is the best starting
place because the leaky gut is really
just
the it's the
it's the diagnosis but it's not
necessarily that your food
test can be your your your gold like
your it's not your bible to what to eat
and what not to eat it's just saying you
have inflammation you have your gut is
not operating properly things are
seeping through and yeah if you have a
diverse diet you're going to see a lot
of stuff on your test and and okay
interesting that makes sense because
you know i mean in my experience i had a
lot a lot a lot of things on my on my
tests that were a level level red level
high
um
okay you had said that you wanted to
talk about vitamin d
yeah the vitamin d is that a hormone as
well it is a hormone as well in fact we
should have named it as a hormone long
ago instead of a vitamin
but one of the things that i guess
didn't surprise me but maybe surprised
me early on one you know and i've been
working in this area for 25 years now
is that all of these patients who
presented with autoimmune diseases just
as a start had very low levels of
vitamin d
and
you know i went it's kind of interesting
um
and then all of these patients with
leaky gut have low levels of vitamin d
and so yeah
so there's there's several important
things um so vitamin d is a hormone i've
never seen vitamin d toxicity uh yet
um and i've been measuring vitamin d
levels every three months for 25 years
uh
i think a normal vitamin d level should
be anywhere from 100 to 150
even the cleveland clinic and quest now
say that vitamin d levels up to 150 are
completely normal not too high
and so i'll
push my patients vitamin d levels up 200
to 150 sometimes we'll go higher
vitamin d does two things um
we have
as as the cells in the wall of our gut
are are hurt by these lectins and other
compounds
there's a bunch of replacement cells
stem cells that are ready to take the
place of these damaged cells it's kind
of like the old revolutionary war movies
where you got lots of lines of soldiers
and the first guys go down and the next
guys step up right
right well that second line
has to be pushed into place by vitamin d
they sit there and twiddle their thumbs
and go what when am i supposed to do
something and it's vitamin d that pushes
them into place that's number one
number two
we know that people with
autoimmune diseases their
immune cells their white blood cells
normally should be sensitive to vitamin
d vitamin d basically says hey guys
relax
go have a donut and a smoke if we think
of them as cops
and that's not to generalize but just
cool it don't carry an uzi around every
everything's fine
but we know that people with autoimmune
diseases their immune cells do not
listen to vitamin d properly so you
basically have to literally hit him with
a sledgehammer to quiet down
so it's this two-fold effect and
so
almost
all human beings should be on 5000
international units of vitamin d
or 125 micrograms any of my autoimmune
patients we start them on 10 000
international units
the university of california san diego
one of the
expert centers in vitamin d thinks the
average american should take 9 600
international units of vitamin d a day
to have an adequate level the average
american
they found and other people found that
you cannot produce vitamin d toxicity at
40 000 international units a day
you're safe and you're safe and i have
some of my really tough autoimmune
patients on 40 50 000 a day
that because of the bioavailability to
their body of what they actually absorb
and do something with excellent question
it turns out when you've got a leaky gut
you do not absorb it well and
long before we had measurements of leaky
gut i used vitamin d levels to decide
when the gut was sealed and so i'd be
pushing pushing pushing vitamin d and
i'd have somebody on 30 000 units and
and their vitamin d would be 50.
and then on the next blood test their
vitamin d is you know 140.
great you know we're there let's start
backing down now and it's actually been
a very reliable
way so you're right
people with leaky gut you just can't
absorb vitamin d well and
once we seal you then your vitamin d
needs go down
got it that makes perfect sense what are
some other kind of hormones that are at
play that are
big factors in
overall health
well um
one of the things that i wrote about in
the last book the energy paradox that i
think people need to know
is
glyphosate the active ingredient in
roundup
is now
omnipresent in our diet
it's in
and people
you know we
we learned about roundup with gmo foods
and you know roundup was developed to
you know spray soybeans and kill the
weeds and the soybeans would die blah
blah blah
and so everybody thinks of roundup as
being sprayed on gmo foods
but and 95 of corn in the united states
is
genetically modified
same with canola
but now what's happened in the last 10
years is the roundup is no longer just
being used on gmo crops it's now being
used on conventional crops as what's
called a desiccant
these large corporations have to bring
these multi-million dollar harvesters to
a field
on a certain day
to be efficient so rather than wait
for the field to ripen and dry
they kill the plants with roundup and
then they die and then they're dry and
so they basically say okay you know
field in iowa number seven is we're
gonna have the harvesters there on next
day spray it with roundup so we can
harvest it
and so nobody's sitting around washing
the wheat or the oats or the corn of
roundup afterwards
they
they don't have to declare it and so
it's fed to our animals it's fed to us
almost all grains united states are
contaminated with roundup
almost all vineyards in the united
states are sprayed with roundup too
mine's clean organic we're organic
very defined
and you know
here in europe and it's you know it's
hard to get uh organic or biodynamic
wine in the united states and bless you
for doing that uh because you know most
of our wines are contaminated with with
roundup now why should we worry about
that well it turns out that glyphosate
is
sadly now known to actually cause
intestinal permeability leaky gut
without doing anything else
and roundup is
roundup was patented as an antibiotic
glyphosate was patented as an antibiotic
was it ever administered as an
antibiotic first before it became
something they sprayed on okay wow but
it's considered an antibiotic yeah it's
it's it's what antibiotics do exactly
and
so
one of the things that they assured us
was that don't worry
roundup is not absorbed and it can't
kill you because you nice people
don't run what's called the shikamate
pathway and that's a really fun word the
shikkamate pathway
and yeah but but plants use the
shikamite pathway what they didn't tell
us was that our bacteria in our gut
used the shikimate pathway
and that's how they patented it as an
antibiotic but they didn't bother to
tell any of us
so
every time you eat a roundup sprayed
grain or bean or corn
you're inadvertently killing off your
gut microbiome and causing leaky gut
even though you're very fastidious about
you know
choosing things
[Music]